la production de cannabis vient de
s'accélérer au québec il ya l'entreprise
9 ailleurs qui vient de démarrer ses
activités dans les dernières semaines à
son usine de boisbriand
c'est un producteur de plus dans un
marché qui tente de s'ajuster on parle
de surcapacité de production dans
certains cas il ya d'autres entreprises
qui ont plutôt réduit justement leur
production récemment on va en parler
avec mark turner et les chefs de la
direction de navailles à merci d'être là
monsieur stuermer les y aider avec vous
ici on va parler d'abord de votre
entreprise comment laventure at elle
commencé à ça commençait à le début de
2010 nice avant ça j'ai un compagnie
dans le piège pour pré marché que j'ai
vendu à une compagnie américaine et à
président en 2017 les compagnies à
français tous les opérations al états
unis alors je reste ici avec une bâtisse
je suis propriétaire et je cherche une
autre opportunité et vexant j'ai
commencé ne varia est-ce que vous
connaissiez le marché du cannabis au
tibi non mais alors le déclic
vous avez donc après demain oui bah tu
sais c'est une industrie qui a explosé
rapidement on a vu l'émergence de
plusieurs grands joueurs dans les
dernières années mais là le marché est
différent il ya d'autres entreprises les
grands de l'industrie aurora canopy
groupe qui en ce moment font des mises à
pied disque surproduction dans le marché
pourquoi vous vous décidez de vous
lancer maintenant nous avons obtenu des
technologies de pointe unique qui permet
un rendement élevé à ses locaux en quoi
ça consiste donc en quoi êtes-vous
différent de ce qui se fait ailleurs
avec cet équipement c'est un équipement
de culture l'occupation verticale avec
cet équipement acquise lors de contrôles
de tous les paramètres de cultive à sion
alors ne vaille est établi de nouveaux
standards pour le docteur l'autorisé qui
chaque mois joël alpy dlp 2.0 est-ce que
ça ça va vous permettre d'être plus
rentables que d'autres entreprises qui
font justement d
mises à pied en ce moment absolument à
ce que tous les paramètres ici en notre
cobaye contrôle et un vrai cannabis
c'est là c'est l'environnement qui a
horreur qui est déterminé les qualités
de produits avec toute cette contrée
c'est un pur produit de qualité de gamme
mais dites moi monsieur starmer il ya
quand même on parle de surproduction
dans le marché vous arrivez vous allez
ajouter vos produits un bassin déjà
existants et s'il ya de la demande pour
ça voilà le marché cherchent des
produits de qualité maintenant il pas
beaucoup de très bonne qualité dans le
marché genevois va offrir ce produit
qu'est ce que vous allez produire
exactement parce qu'il y aura évidemment
le cannabis mais il ya toutes sortes de
produits dérivés aussi on en tant
qu'ancien est de nous concentrer sur la
production de variétés de qualité de
fûts de caravage du fleur afin de maxime
maximiser la qualité du produit et
l'aurait un bon rapport qualité prix
donc pas de produits dérivés
les troupes de mon potager toujours non
pour le penser mais c'est juste de
fleurs et là quels sont vos objectifs de
production quel est le volume que vous
allez produire autant le site va être un
maximum capacités dans 2022 en va
produire plus que son 1000 kg par année
et vous êtes en processus de recrutement
si j'ai bien compris contrairement à
d'autres entreprises du secteur embauche
en maintenant visiter notre site web
navail être point com pour plus
d'informations oui vous avez déjà des
clients
monsieur starmer parce que bon c'est que
des producteurs québécois alors
récemment je pense à camara qui vient de
signer des ententes avec la escudé si
vous en êtes où
quoi premièrement du sommet iliad est
une entreprise basée au québec et nous
travaillons présentement sur une entente
avec calèche coup d'essai et nous
anticipions anticipant anticipons qu'ils
soient en place d'ici la fin d'année
un soigneur à celle et quand vous
tiendra au courant des développements
oui vous savez monsieur bon évidemment
on est dans un contexte de pandémie ça a
un impact sur toutes les activités
toutes les entreprises il ya récemment
d'ailleurs une décote coved 19 dans les
installations de canopy grotte en
ontario est ce qu est ce que ça vous
inquiète la pandémie non ça ne
l'inquiète pas cette business interview
jour la navarre ya évidemment bon vous
avez démarré récemment vos activités à
boisbriand j'imagine que toutes les
mesures sanitaires on avait déjà été mis
en place avant même le début de la
production
oui oui c'est sûr maintenant nous
attendre à recevoir notre permis de
vente plus tard cette année et de
commercialiser les produits à la fin de
2020 2021 au plus tard est-ce que ce
virus là monsieur stormers a un effet
sur les habitudes de consommation à ce
que les gens se tournent plus vers le
cannabis ou se tourner plutôt vers des
fournisseurs légaux et ce qu'ils en
connaissent la colla provenance savent
que c'est mieux encadrer voix c'est une
question de qualité et maintenant il va
y a les qualités et le marché cherche
alors là je pense que c'est brive a
tourné plus qu est ce que disent et les
comme ça est ce que c'est un
investissement majeur que vous avez fait
à boisbriand
très majorettes plus que 20 millions $
déjà est votre objectif vous disiez
évolution recrutement combien d'emplois
vous visez à pleine capacité au juste
cette année navail embauchent plus que
50 employés dans les poubelles
comme l'écrit libération syndication
propagation et pensez vous que vous
allez éviter le sort d'autres
producteurs qui sont justement en
restructuration en ce moment vous
prévoyez koala pour les deux prochaines
années en juge garde un autre
notre business ils ont juste pour que
l'on voie te concentrer sur notre faire
et je pense qu'on va être très très
grand succès dans le marché on vous
souhaite bonne chance merci beaucoup
ok merci beaucoup